hello and welcome to this video against
this won't work I really hope it won't
work what history yeah this line has
served me quite well I think for I mean
I really have never studied it and I
think take this into account my results
are really okay like he has many natural
moves available always like that
uninteresting warfare tries to open up
the diagonal and okay I'm taking and nc6
maybe d5 is a good move now
yeah that's a good opening opening
opening is wrong taking more space this
is what i should say okay
Jim why does a bit better him yep so we
found that moose um yeah as I said I
don't like it if I cheek maybe I should
check do this simplify matters a little
bit who actually made a mistake here
maybe not okay rook takes rook rook
takes the air intakes I was thinking
look Queenie wanessa is a threat but hmm
it's not such a big threat
okay so if i take that i don't quite
understand rook jigsaw okay I mean
Bishop take them ever so it takes with
the rook okay but now if I take on t
five major split screen tags okay
it takes with the Queen I'm going to
look at that and we're all yeah that
pressure on c6 hmm i don't want to play
c5 I can absolutely tell you that but I
didn't really see what else yeah and you
say this won't work this does work what
you're playing very nice the plaintiff
I'm opponent I'm just a little bit worse
I don't I go to be six would have been a
lot more logical okay f6 bishop jakes h6
Bishop takes age 6 so you cannot take
mayor should have played Bishop g6
should be a do I didn't I go to be six
then I would have bishop the aid in one
move I really don't understand my move
sometimes okay um I cannot grab this on
age three ask that could prove very
weakening but chief form I don't want to
see g4 happening
I think you have to prevent it as ugly
as this move looks
i gifted a gifted tim ahora tempo with
should be eight instead of playing
Bishop b6
it takes it 26 just Queen f4 and Bishop
e6 comes time morning
it's a super passive of course but I
just I just had to do something I guess
at five okay
should five don't work check oh wow damn
check check okay black resigns yeah very
good game very good game by this won't
work here all I said I mean I don't know
I defend it as well as I could but Jim
Peter wants to play this move I didn't I
didn't see the big point Jem after this
we should be one that's the engine smoke
which is completely inhuman and didn't
see that one add this is just not I just
a little things added up I think yeah
this is winning a is just winning gym
I definitely don't don't want to be in
this position here a couple of
inaccurate moves are probably the reason
him I don't know it's tough Queen takes
a strong move also i thought i was
expecting Bishop takes but now i have to
play this yeah I know I playing nonsense
this is just a this just doesn't make
any sense but should be six is a lot
stronger and okay of six and Jim I don't
know yeah here you to simply don't
equalize anymore and it just just so
awful on the light squares and actually
had some hope here but probably
completely unjustified the engine gives
this I wasn't even sure if you might be
able to take but I'm not sure about it
and I had some doubts about this ending
I computer seems to believe it is a draw
but it's he can also go here again and
here just just be better yeah I'm not
able to move nutshell it was a very nice
game bye-bye wide simply I'm simply
passive him Joe Joe what what happened
here I mean this this cannot be that
terrible maybe I should just play d5 now
this is this is the thing actually maybe
this is the point that I just should
play d 5 as long as I'm able to and
therefore restrict the bishops no that's
very logical this is what I should do
now that's something to remember I
should go for d5 in this kind of
situation okay so that was an important
point to take from take from this this
disaster of the game thanks for watching